From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Saturday, March 9, 2013. My name is Willie Griffin and I am a research associate with the Southern oral history program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I am with videographer John Bishop in Albany, Georgia on the campus of Albany State University to conduct an interview for the Civil Rights History Project,
which is a joint undertaking of the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress.
We are here today with Miss Mary Jones. Thank you so much for being here, Mrs. Jones, and agreeing to share your story with the Civil Rights History Project.
I just want to begin by asking you simply where were you born and when were you born?
I was born in Georgia, in the 1930s.
1933? Yes.
Okay.
In other words, July of 24, 1933.
Okay. So what was it like to grow up in Albany?
Boy, it was kind of rough. I enjoyed it, but it was kind of rough in those days.
I lived it on a farm seat and a lot of work to do.
A lot of excitement too, I would say.
My grandmother, who real me.
What was her name?
Bertha McIntosh. Bertha McIntosh, okay.
Okay.
Now, my mother's name, you have that already, I do.
But anyway, that was their place that I grew up on. My grandmother's place.
Because of full pants, they bought that little slot of land.
We call it slot-loan.
Slot-loan.
Yeah, slot.
Okay.
And so I grew up on that little slot.
And we knew a lot about going to church.
And when you work during the weekend and you work at church on Sundays.
And from there on too, when I got large enough to really go out and work on the farm,
the white man's farm, like gathering peaked nuts and picking cotton and digging potatoes.
Right.
Is we call it poor corn.
Also pecans gathering pecans.
We couldn't go to school when school started like in September.
We had to stay together at the farm.
And then after you gather the farm, then you could go to school.
And that was around about October, November.
So you missed the first two months of school?
Yeah.
And so when you started doing this type of work, how old were you?
How young were you when you first started?
I probably was about eight.
And my grandmother would let me go with this old lady, Miss Alice Porter.
And she would take quite a few of the children from the neighborhood.
How to do that kind of work in everything.
See, they trusted her because she had children.
She didn't play.
She was a task master.
Yes.
But I loved her because she was always so sweet. She kept us in line.
So after eight years old, then that was our job, like going out.
And sometimes before the farm got ready, we would do a whole and bird speed.
Howing.
Yeah, hoeing.
Explain that. What is that?
That's like a whether Mr. Kina, who used to be the mayor here.
He had a little farm behind I was.
And he would plant bird seeds.
Okay.
And they would come up and we had to hold a grass from around him.
And it was real exciting.
Oh, he paid us pretty good.
Okay.
Like maybe 75 said.
So that was good.
That was a lot of money.
And we would say that money like that to help buy school clothes and that.
Okay.
So what your typical day, your typical work day for an eight year old child is like how long?
I say that when we try to get out there before the sun come up because it'd be so hot.
So I would say around about seven o'clock.
Okay.
And they would have food for us to eat.
So we didn't have to worry about taking lunches.
And we would worry about five.
Five.
And they have to know.
So I said.
And it was in walking distance.
Okay.
So we would get together and all of us lived at right right in the same neighborhood.
So we would get together and walk back to the house that wasn't too far.
So we didn't need a chef around like we did this at a supporter.
We went out to do peanuts and coden and all of that.
Because we all lived at right in neighborhood.
Okay.
So we talked a little bit about when you finally did.
Once the season was over and it was time to pick the crops and you finally got into school.
What was the school, what were the schools like?
The school was when we first started in the church.
First but third is the Baptist church.
It's one of the oldest churches in the Southwest Georgia.
It's like a new boss, a tenant at church.
Visited rather.
W.V. Du Bois?
Wow.
Okay.
And he was so excited about it about how it was.
It was a grid big of something like a bond that the white folks had given us.
Okay.
That we could use.
They used it first and they built them a church and they gave that to us.
Okay.
So.
So that they had special classrooms or did you just hold church like in the...
Hold, it was the whole building.
Okay.
You know, in different areas.
Like first through fifth was in this corner and then the other over there up until the seventh grade.
Wow.
And then we're in a building, a church.
And a matter of fact that's where I went to school until I finished seventh grade.
Okay.
What was in there?
But we started in the church.
Okay.
What was the name of this one that you finished?
Shepherd.
We named it after the master that gave us the big church.
Oh wow.
Because he gave us that ground and stuff so we named it Shepherd.
Okay.
Elementary school.
So what were the teachers like in the school?
Do you have fond memories of them?
Yeah, it is like your mama.
You like it?
You kept you in line.
They kept us in line.
And whip you when you did wrong.
So you had to step out of line.
I tell you.
Okay.
So do you remember any of the names in the church?
Yes.
Miss Willime Jackson was my first grade teacher through third.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
So what type of student were you?
Did you like going to school for the social party?
Yeah.
And for the academics.
Well you go ahead and use going to get that because it's going to make you get your lesson.
Right.
And from fourth through seventh it was Miss Celeste Scott.
Miss Celeste Scott.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
So after seventh grade you went on to high school?
Came to our old building.
You had to come to our old building then.
Okay.
And how was that?
I mean it was a big change, I imagine.
Yeah, that was a big change because we had to find, you know, like some of your relatives
or some to stay with.
Unless you could get your ride back home, maybe they were with people who was working up here
and all being.
But I stayed with my aunt.
Uh-huh.
My three cousins and myself lived with my aunt Ella Holloway.
Ella Holloway?
Uh-huh.
On a chair street.
Okay.
And was that in the primary black community?
Was that in Harlem?
Yeah, that was in the black community.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
And from the, uh, when I came up here we went to Monroe High School, which is still open to the day.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
What do you recall about Monroe?
What was it?
Oh, I lived in Monroe.
I was into sports.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
I played basketball, ran track.
Oh, wow.
So you all around the athlete?
Yeah.
Okay.
And most of my cheer will not.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
What about you?
Um, so you were in high school and then what year did you graduate from high school?
Uh, it's supposed to be 51.
51.
But I was in love and I got married.
That's a good reason.
And he was going to the arm and the next day or so too.
Uh-huh.
And so you got married.
And what was your husband's name?
Jimmy Lee Jones.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
And how did you meet him?
How did he start it?
We started at Monroe.
He was at Monroe.
Okay.
He's playing football in basketball.
And we met like that.
Okay.
So in 1950, I mean, the schools were, I mean, they were segregated.
Yes.
And what were the racial conditions like in the 50s in school?
Was that something that was on your mind?
Were you thinking about race?
Did you, how did you navigate that?
Well, I had, I had listened to the radio and different things like that and read the
paper about it and other citizen thing about this integration.
And I read and bought it and kept it with it.
And I said, well, if it's hit, I'll be in Georgia.
I will show enough beer part of it because I wanted better for my children.
Okay.
Because see, when my children was old enough to go to public schools, they
just integrated in here and all of them.
And they went through so much.
And really did.
Okay.
And you said you were reading about the movement, hearing about it.
What were your sources?
Pitch book, put curd and the southwest Georgia, Miss A.C.
Sugs.
Mr. A.C. Sugs.
Yeah, it was the owner of that paper and did the writing.
Okay.
What did your children have to go through that?
Something that's part of the story that doesn't get told much?
They first integrated the high schools here.
First.
And my oldest daughter was, I signed for her to go to second year.
Okay.
And boy, boy, it was something.
The principal, Mr. McNair, he called them little monkeys.
Because he said that's all he ever called them.
And he couldn't call them nothing else.
And they would have almost a ride every day.
And today I do not understand.
Okay.
Why didn't any, why didn't too many telephones then in the home?
And we didn't have our cell phone.
But every time it starts at all being high, those children for money will be dead.
I don't know how they got there.
But the children got what they didn't want to sit this out of them and you know any cafeteria and all of that.
And they were spit at them and call them all kind of names, monkeys and bells.
And all of that.
How did your children respond to this?
They, she hung in there.
I thought she hung in there.
I think it was about one or two that acted kind of nice, whites.
But she hung in there because so many of her friends went alone when she did.
You know we got them registered and everything.
So she had some friends over there although she had to go through something.
And the teachers I think, she told me she had one or two nice teachers.
Were all of her teachers white at this time?
Did the black teachers lose their jobs when the school's integrated?
Not really now.
I'm trying to think, did she have a black teacher over the whole of the house?
I mean, I got this for a long time.
I'm going to see she's about 60.
But when they started that, like you said, they were transferring black teachers and over to their schools and white teachers over to our schools.
So, but it really didn't help out too much because if it was in there over there, it wouldn't over one or two blacks.
And see everything, you know, it's like my daughter played basketball when she was going to,
and think of the junior high, Carl, junior high.
But when she went over there, you know, no need to replying because they wouldn't have any blacks of monkeys.
They actually used those.
I'm telling you.
So, you said your husband went to the military.
And so, how long was he away?
He went along in the time of the movement starting and everything.
He went back and acted duty.
He was about two years.
But the first time he went, he did two years and came out and then he joined the Resilient.
I'm a Resilient.
So, that's when he was called back and acted duty.
So, what were you doing while he was away?
I mean, obviously you were raising the family, but how did you?
Looking at stories on the TV, because he kept telling me I needed to go on a back and finish
because I was like that was the last year that we had, was graduating from the 11th grade here in 51.
And I played basketball that Friday night and then we got married and Tuesday.
So, they went back until later years.
But I was, you know, in other words, I was a house mama.
That's why I, you know, if you do all the running like backs and fall to school and back and fall
to all the different meetings and things like that.
So, what type of lessons were you trying to instill in your kids if they went to school?
First thing, let them know that they were somebody, regardless of the color of the skin.
And that God loves all of us.
You're not going to school out there to beat up on nobody, take nobody, pence, take nobody or launch money.
You're out there to try to get the loan to be somebody in life.
Now, so when the Albany movement sort of blows up and begins to really take a fact,
your kids are in school at all?
My oldest, my daughter was 11.
And my son was nine.
And I had, well, I really had four children when he went back and served.
I had my last two after he came out.
But anyway, yeah, they were.
They all liked the sports.
It's like we did with my son.
He liked the sports he played football and ran track and high jump.
I forgot about that.
I had jumped too.
All right.
So, the movement, you finally, you say when it comes to Albany, is here now?
Yeah.
How do you respond to it?
I started, I had heard about the Montgomery incident, you know,
about Cardinal L.A.
So, when it first started, the criteria club here had organized and got together.
And I had worked with them in the photo registration.
They didn't get people to register the vote.
Matter of fact, they had a little school like it wasn't a school,
but it was set up in the office that we taught people's had to read.
Because the main incident that they asked for when you go down to register,
and most of the people back didn't have an education.
You had to learn how to read the...
The Georgia Constitution.
Yeah.
That's it.
Okay.
So, when you set out to do these voter registration drives,
how did you go about doing this?
Did you go door to door knocking on door?
Yeah, we had to canvas.
Yeah.
And especially in the projects where I was living, it was so many.
People out there who was not registered to vote, who was scared to go down
because they'd heard, tell all of that, what they had to read.
Most of them couldn't have heard the read.
But after I started working with them in some more,
and had these little classes and things, they got then where they...
I guess they were saying that if Miss Jones died there,
I know it's gonna be alright. She gonna help me.
That's what I did.
Okay.
And even after getting them, you know, registered to vote,
you had to care them back.
I remember one lady told me, and I got so upset about it,
that she told her, carried her to the fly,
about the register and the vote and all that,
and she said she was gonna do it.
So, I talked to the day after.
She said, no, I didn't.
I've registered like you told me.
I said, but maybe you didn't vote.
And that's what counts.
I didn't know.
I just, I said, no, no, no, you know, we talked about that.
Right.
Going through all of that and everything.
And then you don't crash to how will we ever get some black people's in it.
I said, we want to hold it nothing then.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
So, could you...
So, working with that loan with the movement when it started,
and carrying folks back and forth,
dying to get registered.
Okay.
And then, making sure that they go back to vote.
I worked with that a while,
and then I worked on the police committee.
Committee, right?
Uh-huh, with the movement.
Okay.
And you were the first black on this committee, right?
How did this whole process come about?
Did you become the first...
I'm the only one living now.
It was seven of us.
Oh, there were seven of us.
Okay.
And they chose us from the movement, you know,
who would want to be on this committee to go down to talk to Chief Preacher.
Okay.
You know, the different ones,
volunteer to go along with myself.
Miss McCree Harris was I spoke once she was with...
She was working in Monroe High.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
So, I mean, a lot of people, I mean,
Chief Laurie Pritchett is pretty popular as you know.
Yes, he was.
So, what was your opinion of...
Uh-huh.
The first two or three times we went,
he ignored us.
Mm-hmm.
Ignored you.
Uh-huh.
And by the fourth time,
and he knew Miss McCree Harris because she was working at Monroe and was kind of
among the different things that go on here in the city, went on.
Okay.
So, he finally wanted to know,
well, my crew went childworn.
She said, well, we've been here three times and we tried to tell you,
and she said, well, you just told a, told a, told a, uh,
a man over there.
She said, it's like that, the man over there,
tells us to have a seat.
And we said, for our own, almost two hours,
and you never let him come.
So, we got up and left.
And we came back again.
It's the same thing happened.
Mm-hmm.
So, you were so busy.
And then the third time we came,
and so he said, well, I'm just so sorry, you know,
I have so much to do.
And so, uh, he, uh, apologized.
And then he, uh, told her, he said, well, y'all,
there's put the word out and everything.
He said, nobody has been up here to apply for a job.
So, the next time we met, uh, that's the first thing she wanted to know,
had anybody been up there.
He said, no.
So, she said, well, I tell you what, you give me,
to give me some applications.
She said, I go out and I came.
And so, it was, were they all right?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they had to be all right.
So, uh, she did, and from that process, uh,
they did have five, I think it was five, five...
I think it was five, uh-huh.
I thought that was, uh, eat your Smith.
Eat your Smith.
Uh-huh.
David Hyde. Robert Benning. Robert Benning. Yeah. Inserting that big junior.
Because it's what we call it. Most folks didn't know what the name gonna see.
He was working it. They feel wrong. And the other two names. How many day I go?
You said, Eat your Smith, David Hyde and Robert Benning, big junior.
And it's two. It's two mouth. Okay. Is it in a way I can? That's fine. You will.
If you come to me. Yeah, you can get them to me. Okay. Okay. So, but they were told when they was high.
You know, UK, rest know quite folks. And this was and this was in. So they weren't really full.
No, they were full of time for us. Right. But they just couldn't. Oh, no.
Now, did they have police cars? They didn't get patrol cars. They had a walk at B.
You folks, they have regular uniforms. Yeah, they had uniforms. Okay.
Because I know in some cities, you know, they would give them these positions. Yeah.
But they wouldn't give them uniforms. They wouldn't give them patrol cars.
And they couldn't carry weapons.
I was in Texas. Well, they was already cautious. I'm trying to say they had weapons.
But I know they were told that they couldn't rest in a way. And the reason that came about.
The movement decided to start, you know, going up talking to them about this.
Because every week or two, some blacks man got killed.
All you had to do stomach cross that floating and they were killed.
And it was usually at the hands of a police officer. Yes. And we went up and, you know,
swatter them, you know, we don't feel safe because it's just on the white policeman.
They don't want to do any killing. Right.
And the police force is supposed to make you feel safe. Yeah. Every week.
I'm telling you the truth. Somebody got shot. This and that.
So out of that, they did harm. Like I said, and everything.
But they gave them new rooms and regulations.
Do you remember the year that the first black police officers were hired?
Was it in the 60s or 50s?
It was in the 60s. It was in the 60s. It was doing the movement.
They started by last of 61 on the 60s.
It was in the 60s.
I wanted to backtrack a little bit because the criterion club has come up in some
newspaper articles. But no one knows that much about it.
Could you talk about some of the leadership of the criterion club?
And I guess some of the reasons why they formed initially, you said that they formed
initially to, was it voter registration? Was that their primary?
They were doing, they were doing voter registration, but they kind of the one that came in also
with a few more as set up there all been the movement.
Okay. Who were some of the more prominent leaders in the criterion club?
Okay, Dr. William Anderson.
Okay.
Shaveen, Attorney King. Shaveen King.
Thomas Chapman.
Okay.
Good as I know about the page.
Yeah, yeah, page.
I can't even think of his first name now.
Okay.
It was quite a few of them.
They helped organize by they were already, you know, into registration and all of that.
So they chose Dr. William Anderson as the president of the Albany Movement.
Okay.
And then they had Mr. Pays like you call it name, he was a secretary.
And a few more other gone on and on.
I can't think of folk that.
Okay.
So when the Albany Movement, when the students, the freedom writers come in, what are you
thinking?
How does that, I mean, does it, that's what really tipped it off because they came in and
they went out through the country area and all of that.
They came in when suddenly evening on the, they met them come out of my husband, hadn't
gone back into duty then, I had to do the then so they all went down to the train station
and welcome their men.
And that's when they were arrested and.
And they had to mass media every night but Saturday and Sunday.
But if it was necessary for a call meeting, you know, they would.
They moved these mass meetings around or what they always at one particular place.
Now some of the ministers didn't cooperate with it because they were afraid that some
of the churches had gotten burned up and leek in and tear.
Right.
And it was a blessing because it was little shacks anyway.
And when Dr. King and them organizations, they built those churches back, it was so nice.
Okay.
So now, okay, now I didn't hear about, I have heard about the rash of church burnings
in these places.
So Dr. King played a role in getting these.
Yeah, he had getting phones.
Okay.
Yeah.
Could you talk a little bit more about how did that take place?
So I mean, I'm not.
Talk about the burning.
Yeah, the burnings and the.
Because they had mass meetings at those churches.
Okay.
And they were on people's places, you know, plantations and some people were even afraid
of Martin Luther King coming to these churches.
Yeah, they were.
Uh-huh.
But he ended up helping them anyway, rebuild some of these churches.
Yeah.
Of course, he knew all these different organizations and all of that.
And they were able to find, uh-huh, be it intelligent person.
So did you ever get a chance to meet him personally?
King, Dr. King, did you ever get a chance to meet him personally?
Yeah, you know, going by like shaking his hand and the glue man or something.
There'd be so many folks around, and you couldn't get them trying to talk personally.
Right.
So now, when you, um, when they started, when did you decide to become, I mean, involved
in the marches and, and, and so forth?
And you finally, when it, when was the first time you got arrested?
Mm-hmm.
What happened?
It drew out of one of the, the meetings that we were having, mass meetings and things.
And about the march and then all of that.
Well, the children had march first, the young people.
And so they all been here, had printed and also on the, uh, Chantine, uh, which was James
Gray's, uh, Oh, uh, uh, news vapor.
Uh-huh.
And he was saying about the old, the people, the, the grownups, they too scared the march
so they pushed the children out.
They do their work.
Right.
And boy, we had a fit back there, mm-hmm.
Come on, oldest daughter would lock them too, let me know.
So, uh-huh.
A call, a challenge, a good year in call.
Yeah.
And push the cheer or not for it.
Mm-hmm.
So then we said, now that ain't gonna go.
So we organized right there to the mass meeting.
Uh-huh.
And who, who wanted to march and all their hands just went up.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
And so we met around there on the corner of, uh, Washington and Broad Avenue.
Okay.
The next morning.
We marched down watching the street by the old, uh, jail, which was on, uh, uh, uh,
I can't think of that street now, but I know it wasn't Flint.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, mm-hmm.
Could've said no, no, no, no, but anyway, it'll come back.
But anyway, about 700 us, uh, grownups.
Okay.
So we went to the large, uh, actual, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
so, uh, the thing that we had to strayed not because they said we sent for Martin Luther
King to come do our job.
Right.
We didn't send for him.
To come march, because 700 was in jail when he came.
Right.
Uh-huh.
So this is strictly a local movement and just came.
So I was in there from Monday about 11 o'clock to Thursday.
Uh-huh.
My father came and, uh, bond me out.
Okay.
But in a way, uh, so what, I mean, before you go into the, okay, that's what I want you
to do.
Ask me what you want me to say.
Okay.
The, um, the marching, I mean, walking with 700 people.
How does that, I mean, how does that make one a person feel?
I mean, you have one or one.
We is an average A.R.
Right.
I went to, uh, Baker, kind of jail.
Okay.
When you were arrested, how did they treat you?
Were they, were they hostile with a strong hand?
Yeah.
They had the Billy Club get on in here.
You marching, they had warned us one time.
If you don't stop that saying and go home, you're going to be locked up and we got
lied again.
Ain't going to let nobody turn me around.
Uh-huh.
And so we marched around by two more times and shabbling up.
They, uh, told us we was under arrest.
And back then the jail was so small that had a little place in the back.
But it wasn't, it wasn't biggest, it was about biggest from where he said it over here.
Okay.
And that's where they put 700 of us.
Wow.
We was all on top each other almost and we stood, they let you stood out there about three
or four hours and it was pouring down rain then.
Uh-huh.
Then they finally, uh, let us come in and they booked us.
Mm-hmm.
And they sent us different places.
I was in to remember the name of the jet around here that wouldn't take any of us.
It didn't want to have anything to do with it.
I can't thank a, what?
I'm telling you.
So there was one county that wouldn't have been with you.
Uh-huh.
That's a no we aren't taking any.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
I can't thank a, to save my life.
That's okay.
Uh-huh.
But, uh, so I mean, how did they, I mean, wouldn't it be?
What did you do in the 700?
How did you go to the rest room, the, the eat that they feed you?
Yeah.
Up there, uh-huh.
Uh, the little room down there to make a kind of where, where I was.
It actually would hold, look like about eight or ten.
Mm-hmm.
And they put 25 in there.
Uh-huh.
Mm-hmm.
One bit.
Wow.
And the那, what's going on?
Everything nice.
We have to, like, twenty thirty.
What.
So.
Well got out.
음, got out ofلب.
So before, you were, you were in the Ihrvenor projections eg,
a long time.
Everybody started up to think of,
and he needed to.
And another name out of there.
A lot of ど the most,
one thing you noticed,
uh, whatенan,
what do you say?
Everything.
Um-hmm.
And Lemme.
Uh-huh.
Just on the British earth people.
exactly the way they were. And they were made them dogs. So, man, they'd be barking and going on.
And they said, we ought to go in there. We ought to open the gate and let these dogs go in there and eat them up.
And see what they do then. That's what we need to do. And boy, we were sing louder and pray and
everything. Then when they feed you food, I told some of them, I said, when I go home, I said,
the peas that I'm going to cook, I'm going to be able to drink them. The peas are so hard,
you couldn't hardly cut them. Couldn't you eat them? Grits the same way. And they'd take their
butter and put red and the mill of the grits and throw the bread on top of it. And that's what they
gave us. They gave us the grits and our bread and peas, blackout peas, like that. And we were so tired
and they were just, who would I tell you the truth? It was rough and tough. But if I had to do it again,
I would have done that. Because they were studying March and as we, you know, was got out. And I tried
to go back, but they wouldn't arrest me. They wouldn't arrest you. See, we knew how to dress. Then they
told us how to put on extra clothes, you know, up on your pants and what like that. It was two
men that I'm going to jail and had no way to put us. We just continued to march.
So it was really rough and tough, but it was worth every bit of it. And of course,
we had some good white friends too. That really helped out. You know, a lot of them couldn't come
out to the front. You know, they helped. Do you remember any particular? No. They really,
they called the name, but they was kind of quiet. But it didn't mean for nothing to get back.
Because they would end up doing them the same way. End of that paid us in their attention.
See how they did the civil rights leaders that came in and then
she wrote in them. They didn't make no difference with them. If you decided with us,
blacks, like now they won't call us black. Then if you associated with niggas,
you got just what the niggas got. So they were going to jail. So you see, all this came about
because I was leaders like the criteria and clubs and some menaces and others had gone now and
tried talking with the city manager. Then I could think his name, told with preaching them,
you know about the situation here. And they wouldn't even talk to them.
No, you ain't got nothing to talk about. They just wanted you to stop. Oh yeah. But after
got so many and they see that it won't be no stopping. Then they didn't. They did. But before
they did that, we had to cut off all ties with the down town. We started going to motry getting
our clothes and all that kind of stuff. They gave us time to get out. It must come at the
Christmas. They gave us time to get out of their way. And once you got them out,
all of them was a black Christmas. Folks was going to come Miller and
call the ill place like that and we mostly was going and I was taking people to
to motry. So the boycott was the success. Yeah, the boycott was the old eight star
standing for you then. Warner talk. During Christmas. It was coming up to Christmas when I
went to jail because we had gotten our things out. I believe it was the first Monday and December.
Okay. Get out of your layaways. That's where we shot them by layaways. You know putting that stuff
up and paying. I heard about the layaways system. Okay. So now when your father comes to get you out of
jail, what's the first thing you do? What do you do? How do you feel? I feel so good. I'm telling you,
I wanted to see my children because my neighbor next door, she was overseeing them. Because she had
a day out me to go to jail. She knew I was going to go out all the way to jail. As it wasn't hit
all the time. I'm sorry. You've been out to go with jail. This is your time, no right? Yeah.
I was real happy and everything. Now some of the people I thank a lot was money in that deal.
Because that was the first beginning of it where they tell you you could put your house
up or either pay. I forget how much the fine wall. But a lot of that they kept that money in
stuff. So they made a lot of money as well? Yeah. And your father just, but he didn't lose nothing.
He didn't lose anything. Okay. So after this, you go back out and you march some more.
And is that the extent of your participation, how do you continue to stay involved?
Yes. I stayed in the far down. I couldn't go to jail. My mom, they wouldn't arrest me.
I took home then.
That's the mission. Okay. Sorry.
I then I was living in the Washington projects, which is right down over there. You can't tell
it. Now, because I think they got a golf course down there. But it was so many of us living out
there in the project. Then we kind of, even the movement was going on each night.
They would meet at my house at 12 o'clock every day. Sure.
I didn't. Okay. And that would give all the older people who wasn't able to really walk down
the shallow of my side from the projects over there on the street. Okay. They would give them a
chance to come to the meetings too. Okay. And we would have that, that plus I would
think that's one of the voting captains. Okay. That was, I wasn't one out there. Well, street
project that they would tell it to mask me who we were going to vote for. Because we had our
people there. Right. The ones that were going to do right and everything. So then I would
call them and let them know or either go right into the house that makes they and let them know who
to vote for when they go to vote. Okay. Okay. So I guess just looking back, reflecting back on
Albany's movement. The successes and failures. Where would you pin those if there were any failures
successes? I wouldn't say failure. Because love knows when we were before we started, before it began.
I would say it was a success because that come up to the schools and all of that. And
then our people looked like a lot of really called on and began to try to do for their children
and bring them up the right way and everything. And then good jobs open up and everything.
Because we wouldn't have them good jobs if you did. You was just like our best department stuff.
We had to pick it their place for the longness for they were having the likes, besides cleaning
them up. But they finally come up around because they know they were closed for that Christmas
or we didn't shop here. So when I go to those schools and I all these
told them you weren't working in them, not running them cash register, not only clean up
and go pick up the mayor and things like that and to watch black people when they come in.
So if there are any legacies that you would want, you know, known about Albany's movement,
I mean what would be the most important thing that you would want people to know?
One thing, much prayer. And then sticking together and not going back to the old
Uncle Tom ways. Everything that you know they try to do, I sneak off at night and go tell him,
my boss man, you know or whatever. We had a lot of snitches.
But they didn't fuss out them and then they let them know they knew who they were.
But they didn't have to call it name but they could tell us so plain because they know who they were.
And I would say you know by sticking together, first thing was like I told you much prayer
and then sticking together and we learned how to love more then because
back then we was kind of off and love each other. We got where like we hated each other.
Like white man hated. You think we've gotten to that point now?
We get into it. We ain't toured all together but we're working on it.
So we're trying to let that be a legacy about doing the right thing.
Not only about black people but white people too because it's like I told you we had some good white folks
in there. And another committee I thought about I wanted to talk about. We had all kind of
committed from the movement and one thing I wanted to make sure about the teachers because the
superintendent had told them if they marched that's what they job. They could not march.
So now what is more important? March and going to jail and you don't have no job are either
helping the people who went to jail and that's what they need. They organize and people's march
they sell about their children. They bought food, paid light meals, paid the rent. I'm telling you what I
know. So they paid on they played a young part of the road and they all been in movement. You don't
hear about it too much. Yeah, those stories you definitely don't. You don't hear about but I know
about it because I was there. They played the importer road because they didn't have to worry about
nothing. And one day we had and wasn't late. She was older than me but she sold they've all.
So she heard about that and they was telling her what happened. She said well I can go to jail
because he folks ain't buying or even on his stuff know how they got no money. So I can go to jail
so she did. She went three or four times and her life was paid her rent and when she got out she had
food and thought they they they they they they and therefore people like myself and others who didn't
have the money you know you wanted to do something but you really didn't have nothing. Uh-huh.
So I wanted to say that because they really played an importer road in this movement.
It was well put. When the thing is you I want to ask I want to take a bow.
No man Mrs. Jones I really appreciate I want to thank you again for sitting down and taking the
time and and sharing these wonderful stories that you have and we appreciate it. Yeah and I
told you about my educational background. Because I didn't do that until after you know the movement
well all doing the movement that's when that came out. Okay. The wall poverty uh John. President
Johnson was the president and Sergeant Shriver was over that problem and a head start problem.
Now they get me stood up when they start talking about cutting them funds for head start. Right.
Because I know where my education came from. And you went into early childhood at that beginning.
Uh-huh. Sure did. And 15 I was on a master but I promised a good low. I'd go in home with that.
But I got it was just too hard. I had to go to the old.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of
African American History and Culture.